depuis le début de la pandémie plus les
semaines passent plus la coved 19
atteint les jeunes au pays ça ne seront
pas forcément du que on a droit
maintenant d'aller dans des bars ou
autre ça me semble un peu évident que ça
se passe comme ça
un exemple du tout les jeux voix et
c'est plein de monde sur les médias
sociaux qui font des rassemblements qui
des événements qui ce qui se passe c'est
que ça m'étonne pas du tout les caisses
à soi cette portion l'aixois le plus
touché en ce moment on fait le taux
d'infection chez les jeunes a
pratiquement doublé au québec
en trois mois il est passé de 13,6 pour
cent à 22 9 % alors qu'au canada il est
passé de 16 9% à 23,8 pour ça et parmi
tous ces cas le virus a fait une
première victime de moins de 20 ans au
québec ce que ce décès le nourou montre
c'est que la maladie peut frapper
n'importe qui à n'importe quel âge c'est
rarissime dit elle mais le virus b est
bel et bien les jeunes plus susceptibles
de se retrouver dans des fêtes et des
rassemblements
ce qu'on voit c'est que dans la deuxième
vague ou bien dans l'antre vague de la
pandémie à travers la planète c'est le
même scénario qui se passe c'est
vraiment des personnes qui sont
infectées
ces images par exemple d'une énorme faim
est à wuhan en chine berceau de la
pandémie ont fait le tour du monde
j'ai vu ces photos dit cet
épidémiologiste de l' oms
mais des scènes comme ça il y en a
presque partout dans le monde
pourtant les jeunes ne sont pas
invincibles on sait pas comment je vais
réagir à ça je sais que j'ai pas
d'autres problèmes de santé qui peuvent
entraîner regard des difficultés
respiratoires mais on sait jamais
difficile de dire avec précision quel
est le taux de mortalité chez les jeunes
mais avec le décès de ce jeune homme de
19 ans la corvée 19 ans maintenant fait
neuf victimes chez les moins de 30 ans
au pays
ici sébastien desrosiers radio canada
morin